♪ ♪
SPIN ON THE CROP OF 2022
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES GOT
STRONGER AS HERSCHEL WALKER
ANNOUNCED THAT HE IS JUMPING
INTO THE G.O.P. SENATE PRIMARY
TO TAKE ON INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT
RAFAEL WARD OUT, TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'M CONSERVATIVE NOT BECAUSE
SOMEONE TOLD ME TO BE, I'M
CONSERVATIVE BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IN SMALLER GOVERNMENT, A STRONG
MILITARY, A PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKING SURE
ALL PEOPLE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PURSUE THEIR DREAMS, THAT'S
IN AMERICA WORTH FIGHTING FOR.
>> HERSCHEL WALKER AT THE 45.
>> MY NAME IS HERSCHEL WALKER,
AND I AM RUNNING FOR
UNITED STATES SENATE.
I'M A KID FROM A SMALL TOWN IN
GEORGIA WHO HAS LIVED THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
>> Sean: HERSCHEL WALKER JOINS
US.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WE HAVE BEEN FRIENDS A LONG
TIME, AND BY THE WAY, BUCKLE UP,
JUST ENTERED THE BLOOD OF
POLITICS, AND I SEE THE ATTACKS
HAVE ALREADY BEGUN.
AND I LAUGH, BECAUSE I KNOW YOU
PERSONALLY, THEY WILL NOT
INTIMIDATE YOU, EVEN SOME
REPUBLICANS WILL JOIN IN FORCES
AND YOU WILL STAY IN THE RACE
FOR SURE, WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO
MAKE THIS JUMP?
WE NEED LEADERS LIKE YOU, YOU
ARE A LEADER, A NATURAL BORN
LEADER.
>> FIRST OF ALL, SEAN, LET ME
SAY THIS YEAR THAT I WANT
EVERYONE TO GO TO
.com .
BECAUSE YOU ARE RIGHT, THE LEFT
AND THE RIGHT ARE COMING AFTER
ME, BUT IF THEY ARE READY TO GET
DOWN IN THE SWAMP, YOU'RE
LOOKING AT IT RIGHT HERE.
BECAUSE I DON'T CARE, I DON'T
WANT TO SIT ON THE SIDELINE
ANYMORE AND SEE THIS --
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THIS
COUNTRY, BECAUSE THIS IS NOT THE
AMERICA I GREW UP IN AND NOT THE
AMERICA I WANT TO LEAVE FOR MY
KIDS OR ANYONE ELSE'S KIDS, I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
STRONG MILITARY AND WE CANNOT
BE -- GIVE OUR WORD AWAY.
HOW IN THE WORLD CAN YOU LEAVE
YOUR ALLIES?
YOU GAVE THEM YOUR WORD.
HOW CAN YOU LEAVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
WE NEED LEADERS THAT I SET A
LONG TIME AGO TO GO TO
WASHINGTON AND DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT THEM RIGHT
HERE, THAT'S WHY TOLD YOU RIGHT
NOW, GO TO TeamHerschel.com
AND I GUARANTEE I WILL FIGHT FOR
YOU.
>> Sean: YOU SAY THAT, AND WE
HAVE TALKED A LOT OVER THE YEARS
AND BECOME FRIENDS OVER THE
YEARS AND I THINK I WANT
EVERYBODY TO KNOW ABOUT YOU IS
YOU ARE ARE GUIDED BY YOUR OWN
PRINCIPLES, YOU DON'T --
YOU DID NOT GET IN THIS RACE
WITH ANY IDEA THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO LOSE, AND WHEN I SPOKE
TO YOU RECENTLY YOU SAID, SEAN,
MY ONLY GOAL IS TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF GEORGIA.
MY WHOLE LIFE IT'S BECAUSE OF
GEORGIA.
YOU TOLD ME THAT.
>> AND I HAVE, I HAVE TOLD YOU
THAT, AND I HAVE SAID IT MANY,
MANY TIMES.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT HERSCHEL IS
NOT OF GEORGIA, I SAY I OWE
EVERYTHING TO GEORGIA.
EVERYTHING TO GEORGIA, MY
PARENTS, BUT MOSTLY TO THE STATE
OF GEORGIA, BECAUSE WHATEVER
I'VE DONE THE STATE OF GEORGIA
HAS NOT BEHIND ME RIGHT NOW.
AND RIGHT NOW IT IS PIVOTAL THAT
THIS STATE HAVE A CONSERVATIVE
LIKE MYSELF TO GET IN WASHINGTON
AND LET THE PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THIS COUNTRY IS GOING DOWN THE
DRAIN UNLESS WE STAND UP.
AND TO BE HONEST, SEAN, I NEED
TO SAY THIS COMING YOUNG PEOPLE
OUT THERE, YOU KNOW, I WAS LIKE
YOU, SOMETIMES I STAND ON THE
SIDELINE AND I DID NOT VOTE.
I FIGURED IT'S NOT GOING TO
TOUCH ME, BUT RIGHT NOW I WILL
TELL YOU WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW, YOU NEED TO WAKE UP.
WAKE UP AND SAY I HAVE TO GET
INTO THIS GAME.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
I AM GOING TO GET INTO THE GAME
AND I WILL SAY, GOD, THIS IS NOT
THE AMERICA I GREW UP IN.
THIS IS NOT THE AMERICA I WANT
TO BE A PART OF.
WE ARE A GREAT COUNTRY, SO QUIT
TRYING TO DIVIDE US.
QUIT TRYING TO SEPARATE US.
BECAUSE WE ARE TOGETHER.
THIS IS THE REASON WE ARE THE
GREATEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD,
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT COME
TOGETHER.
AND WHAT I WANT TO DO IS BRING
THE PEOPLE TOGETHER.
I WANT TO GO TO WASHINGTON AND
TRY TO GET PEOPLE TOGETHER SO WE
CAN GET THINGS DONE FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
GET THINGS DONE FOR THE PEOPLE.
IT IS SAD THAT PARENTS NOW CAN
EVEN GO TO THE STORE AND AFFORD
DIFFERENT THINGS.
GAS PRICES ARE GOING OFF THE
ROOF, THINGS ARE JUST GETTING
RIDICULOUS AND YOU CAN'T DO IT.
YOU CAN'T DEAL LIKE THIS.
>> Sean: I'VE ASKED YOU, LOWER
TAXES, TELL ME WHERE YOU DON'T
SUPPORT?
SCHOOL CHOICE?
LAW AND ORDER, ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, SECURE BORDERS,
CONSTITUTIONALIST ON THE BENCH,
YOUR SUPPORT FREE AND FAIR
TRADE, PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
YOU BELIEVE IN LIBERTY, FREEDOM,
CAPITALISM AND OUR CONSTITUTION,
ALL TRUE?
>> THAT'S ALL TRUE, THAT'S ALL
TRUE, YOU KNOW, YOU STARTED
TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION, WHY IS
THERE NOT ONE EDUCATION, BUT
EDUCATION FOR EVERYONE INSTEAD
OF HAVING TWO OR THREE, WHY
DON'T WE HAVE ONE WHERE EVERYONE
WILL GO TO GET A GOOD EDUCATION
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT IS SO
IMPORTANT AND WHAT WE HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR THE RESPONSIBILITY,
RIGHT NOW THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO
DO IS BRING BACK RESPONSIBILITY.
GO TO TeamHerschel.com AND
GIVE $